Borderlands 3 is a welcome return to
form for the franchise it reunites fans
with the core group of memorable main
characters from the first two games and
delivers the mayhem heavy loot shooter
experience if the series is known for
though there are a few stumbling blocks
Borderlands 3 introduces noticeable
improvements to the series formula
providing additional freedom and how you
want to play
[Music]
as one of four fledgling vault hunters
you are recruited into the crimson
raiders and drawn into the war against
Iran Calypso and her twin brother Troy
the Calypso twins are using their
influence as popular video streamers to
convince their cult following to help
them acquire the power found in secret
vaults scattered throughout the universe
don't forget to like follow and obey
looting and shooting are still the focus
of Borderlands 3 but its campaign also
delivers a fairly well-written story of
sacrifice the importance of family and
the responsibilities of heroes
Borderlands 3 provides more flexibility
than ever before to create the type of
character you want for the first time in
the series the vault hunters all have an
active skill tied to each of their three
respective skill trees using perks from
all three skill trees you can evolve
each of these skills in meaningful ways
as a result it's pretty easy for both
you and a friend to be playing as the
same character but have completely
different builds and roles on the
battlefield this added freedom also
makes it far more feasible and thus
enjoyable to play Borderlands threes
campaign entirely solo
the freedom to build your ideal loadout
extends beyond your vault hunter skill
trees borderlands 3 makes clear-cut
distinctions when it comes to the
manufacturer of each gun before you even
loot a new firearm looking at which
company made it will tell you most of
what you need to know about what it can
do they're mostly minor changes to
further differentiate each type of gun
but these new manufacturer effects make
it a lot easier to build specialized
loadouts that can augment the perks you
choose but more than anything the guns
are just fun to shoot
it may come as little surprise given
that distinctive firearms have been the
bread and butter of the franchise but
Borderlands 3 has quite a few unique
guns that offer a wide variety of
enjoyable effects and you acquire new
firepower at a gratifying pace with new
loot regularly dropping from the tougher
enemies and erupting from boss as you
defeat Borderlands 3 never lets up on
giving you new weapons to experiment
with it progressively increases the
explosive potential and wacky effects of
the weapons you find indicative of how
much stronger you're getting as
entertaining and flexible as Borderlands
3 combat is the fun is occasionally
interrupted by the structure of boss
battles many of the bosses look cool and
have incredible theme music but they all
amount to the same strategy shoot the
weak spots run from or jump over attacks
and repeat pretty much every boss in the
game has a large health pool and many of
the later ones are bullet sponges so
when you do encounter a boss in
Borderlands 3 it typically grinds the
mayhem filled action to an abrupt halt
the new climbing and sliding moves do
allow you to better navigate
environments and thus get out of the way
of certain attacks but both mechanics
are better suited for weaving among the
scattered firefights with normal enemies
not the concentrated bombardment of the
bosses thankfully boss battles only make
up a small part of Borderlands 3s
overall campaign most of the story sees
you go up against the calypso seemingly
never-ending cult of bandits or the
armies of the twins corporate sponsors
your journey takes you far beyond the
planet of Pandora and provides
opportunities for different types of
combat encounters borderland 3's
campaign sees you bouncing back and
forth between planets every few hours
which keeps each setting from growing
stale even if Borderlands 3 takes you
far beyond the scope of Pandora and seas
you meet brand new allies and encounter
never-before-seen threats the original
cast of characters that have defined the
adventures from the beginning are still
at the forefront and the story is better
for it whether you're a longtime fan or
not it's the connection to the crimson
raiders that acts as your motivation for
fighting through the campaign
Borderlands heroes are nothing if not
personable and that trend continues in
this latest installment newcomer main
villains the Calypso twins are clearly
bad people but the campaign story never
gives you a compelling reason as to why
you would want
to kill them and stop them for good the
clips of twins instead feel like the
primary source of much of Borland
Three's comic relief not true villains
[Music]
it's on sanctuary 3 with your crew that
Borland threes well-written story delves
into it's more heartfelt and emotional
moments the game wastes little time
reintroducing you know mainstays Lilith
and Patricia Tannis and building the
drama of its narrative around them as
the two women grow into their new roles
within the Crimson Raiders for two
characters that were popular but little
more than caricatures in the first game
it's rewarding to see the growth that
two underwent in Borderlands 2
now calm it into two leaders that you're
willing to follow to the end Borderlands
three is a few stumbling blocks when it
comes to bosses but these fights are
overshadowed by the game's rewarding
gunplay and over-the-top humour the
character driven narrative acts as a
satisfying finale for the loot shooter
franchise and the new mechanics and
features give you plenty of agency and
how you want to play through it if
you've never been a fan of the franchise
it's unlikely Borderlands 3 does enough
things differently to change your mind
but the game certainly excels at
continuing what the series has always
done best delivering a humorous tall
tale of misfits looting and shooting so
you're kicking ass with the Raiders
guess we'll have had to replace me
eventually ready for some more action
that's why I'm here asses and kicking
button
[Music]